-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Roy Wood Jr.
We both work on shows
that talk about the news.
I would love to get your take on
the McCarthy vote chaos.
-What is -- What's wrong
with our country, man?
'Cause, like, it's one thing to
laugh about what's happening
with the Republicans
and not being able to vote on
the speaker or whatever,
but, also, don't forget,
while this is happening,
government is not happening.
-Yeah.
-Our government has not started.
You're back to work.
-Yeah.
-I'm back to work.
They're back to work.
Our government
is just still just --
You ever been at a fast-food
spot during the shift change?
-Uh-huh.
-That's essentially what's
happening in D.C. right now.
It's just somebody keep
counting down the register.
The money ain't right,
so they got to keep counting
the register again.
And I'm just here
for a little government.
I just want a little government
and some fries.
But I just -- I don't --
I really hate that.
I hate the fact that you have
all of these new politicians
who worked hard
during midterms to be elected,
and now they have to sit
and twiddle their thumbs,
because no one
can even be sworn in.
-Yeah.
-You can't even --
You got the job, and just,
"Yeah, I'm sorry that..."
"Hey, you got hired
at 'Seth Meyers,'
but we haven't voted on
a new Seth Meyers yet.
You can't work."
And so I think
that part of it, I think,
is what is lost in a lot of
the debate on all of this, man.
But it's fun to watch, though.
-It is fun to watch.
You --
-Watching Republicans fight like
this, it's like watching --
You ever seen a family fight
at Golden Corral?
It's like that.
You be like, "I don't want to be
a part of that family,
but that's
an interesting family."
-It's going to be
an interesting year for
everyone over at
"The Daily Show."
Obviously, Trevor announced
he was leaving
after a seven-year run.
In his announcement,
which I believe
caught everybody off guard,
he mentioned that you
had just --
-Don't point, don't point,
don't point.
-Well, I feel like
I didn't do the pointing,
but Trevor did say
you had just said to him,
"Can you believe
it's been seven years?"
-That's all --
And that's all I said.
That's all I said.
And then the liberal media...
[ Laughter ]
They somehow took --
Here's what happened.
The day before
Trevor stepped down --
The day before Trevor announced
that he was going to step down
from the show, I said,
"Hey, man, seven years, man.
Today, it's been seven years."
And he just went...
And I was like,
"What was that [bleep]"
He was like, "Nothing."
And then, the next day,
he announced.
And I didn't say it
in the sense of,
"Hey, man, you need to get
the hell out of here."
It's like, imagine if you told
your wife "happy anniversary,"
and then, the next day,
she was like, "I'm leaving."
You're like, "What?!"
So, yeah, but, you know,
I'm very happy for him, man.
I'm happy for him
making that choice for himself.
-I'm happy for him, excited to
see what's next for him.
I know you're going have
a rotation of hosts.
You're going to get to
do it for a week.
I'm looking forward to that.
-At some point.
But, you know,
we got a gang of celebrities
coming in first, man.
-I mean,
there's a lot of big names.
Have you worked with
some of these people before?
-Yeah, it's going to be
a blessing, man,
to really be able to sit down
with the likes of --
I've opened for
these people on the road,
but to actually sit and create
late-night television
for four days with Wanda Sykes
and Marlon Wayans, Leslie Jones,
Chelsea Handler,
Sarah Silverman --
Al Franken is stepping up
in that thing.
The only week
I'm nervous about is Chelsea.
-Uh-huh.
This is Chelsea Handler.
-I'm nervous about
Chelsea Handler week.
-Now, where do
your nerves come from?
-Because back in '07, I said
some wild [bleep] on her show.
-Okay.
-And you know how you be
a guest on somebody's show,
you say something wild,
and then the producers
don't have you back?
-Uh-huh.
-And then you be like,
"Man, I ain't gonna never
see her again.
It don't matter."
And then I'm like, "Oh [bleep]"
-Do you remember what you said
that got you in trouble?
-What it was -- Like,
you remember "Chelsea Lately"?
They talked about celebrity,
pop-culture stuff.
And I don't remember the year,
but it was a story about
Sylvester Stallone
getting Botox.
-Uh-huh.
-This was, like, a big --
For the young people,
this was a big conspiracy
back in the day.
Like, "What?
A man with muscles took
something to get more muscles,
to straighten out his skin?"
And I don't re--
What I said was to --
I'm going to just tell you,
because I trust you.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Who gives a [bleep]
I like his movies.
I don't care if
he take cocaine."
And whatever it was,
one of the producers --
Somebody --
Whatever it was, I just --
I was never invited
back to the show.
And I don't think that was
Chelsea's call,
but it's just
one of those things where
when I'm around Chelsea when she
coming to host "The Daily Show,"
I ain't saying [bleep]
about Sylvester Stallone.
-That's probably very safe.
-My mouth's shut.
But, yeah,
I'm very excited about this.
-When your week
does come around,
who do you want to interview?
Who would you
love to sit down with?
-Oof!
Two people.
Give me Samuel L. Jackson...
-Great choice. A great choice.
-...and Solange Knowles.
-Alright. A very...
-I hosted
the Essence Music Festival
a couple of years ago,
and Solange
was one of the performers.
And as a host,
you get to see the sound check.
And I wish everyone
had the opportunity to watch
the gift that is an
artist preparing and rehearsing.
And what she did was
so methodical and scientific
in how she presented her art.
Like, it literally changed
the DNA of me as a performer.
So to be able to
have a conversation,
to ask a bunch of
questions about that,
like, that would be
the ultimate.
And Sam Jackson, I just want to
borrow one of his Kangols.
-Yeah, man, I get it.
I think he always comes with
like a suitcase full of them,
so that's --
-He got 'em
in his hip like Batman.
He "bap-bap" and put one on.
-Hey, man,
thank you for being here.
It's always such a pleasure.
-I appreciate you, brother.
-Happy New Year.
-Good to see you.
-Roy Wood Jr.
The "The Daily Show" returns
from hiatus January 17th.
We'll be right back.